bonjour et bienvenue au forum radio j
dont vous ouvrez avec nous patrick
mignola la 34e saison leur guerre en
ukraine crise de l'énergie enjeux
climatiques inflation record incertitude
est connue comment dans un contexte
aussi incertain rassurer les français à
la veille du débat budgétaire il en
cette rentrée 2022 la droite réclament
des économies la gauche veut taxer les
riches et les super profits des
entreprises comment faire adopter le
budget 2023 d'ici quelques semaines sans
passer par le 49 frappe pure de là quid
des réformes à venir comment notamment
engagée celle des retraites
éventuellement ces de la proportionnelle
mais pour commencer patrick vignal le
contexte économique social ou encore
géopolitique
est ce que cela fait de cette rentrée
2022 celle de tous les dangers par hugin
c'est un danger
c'est au fond c'est pas un danger pour
la démocratie
c'est pas un danger
pour emmanuel macron pour la majorité
c'est un danger si on n'essaye pas
d'objectiver le débat c'est à dire c'est
à dire sur chacun des sujets gunet cité
essayer de se mettre les idées au clair
et plutôt qu'essayer de les utiliser les
exploiter politiquement et
électoralement au quotidien
au fil de polémiques secondaires qu'on
soit capable de donner une vision aux
français parce que ils n'ont pas besoin
d'être rassurés comment comment
rassurerait des enfants
ils en ont besoin il faut leur dire la
vérité c'était un peu le rosé pas c'est
le rôle qu'il assume temps commission
comme commissaire au plan le sait quand
quand il a été le premier à enfin re
dire la vérité sur la crise de l'énergie
c'était avant l'ukraine et parce qu'il
fallait lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique il fallait qu'on électrifie
l'économie il fallait qu'on évite les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre si
demain on veut limiter le gaz à effet de
serre tous les modèles le démontre on a
besoin du nucléaire ben voilà on dit la
vérité aux français on dit le
réchauffement climatique c'est d'abord
le gaz à effet de serre donc c'est
l'utilisation des hydrocarbures si
demain on veut plus utilisés
d'hydrocarbures sont électrifiés et on
n'arrivera pas à maintenir le modèle de
société qu'est le nôtre si on a pas
d'énergie nucléaire là on va en reparler
du nucléaire mais d'abord justement
c'est un peu lié à ça en cette rentrée
2011 c'est un dossier sensible très
sensible et bien c'est l'augmentation
des prix de l'énergie est ce que on vit
une crise comparable à celle de 1973
après la guerre de kippour
je crois que le la situation est un peu
différente air qui règne il ya d'abord
une conjonction de
deux situation inflationniste la
première situation inflationniste c'est
au lendemain de la grave crise
historique du coc vides il y avait une
limitation des échanges mondiaux ils
sont repartis à la hausse est donc
naturellement ça a créé de la tension
inflationniste est venu s'ajouter à sa
la tension inflationniste de la guerre
en ukraine sur la question spécifique de
l'énergie alors pas particulièrement
pour la france parce que la france était
protégé justement par son parc nucléaire
mais parce que nous sommes dans une
économie ouverte et que dans l'ensemble
des pays européens il ya eu aussi des
tensions inflationnistes qui sont venus
s'ajouter et grosso modo pour les
français qui subissent aujourd'hui
environ 6 % d'inflation si on veut dire
des choses simple sans être simpliste la
moitié de l'inflation est due à la
reprise économique mondiale et l'autre
moitié de l'inflation est due à
l'énergie mais nous avons protégé les
français de ce point de vue là sert
toutes les décisions qui ont été prises
depuis une année on limiter
l'augmentation de l'inflation core et
d'aujourd'hui est plutôt à 10 ou 12
saisir que vous dites vous dites que la
france vous considérez que la france
s'en tire mieux que les autres
ça ne signifie pas qu'ils aient des
quais pas d'inquiétude équipe a des
difficultés il ya des personnes qui se
font du souci pour l'hiver prochain pour
savoir comment elles vont se loger et
c'est la raison pour laquelle
aujourd'hui il faut travailler sur la
façon de délier à l'échelon européen
le prix du gaz et le prix d'électricité
parce que selon les types de production
électrique qu'on a dans les pays s'il
est extrêmement liés au gaz ça peut
faire un doublement ou à un triplement
du prix de l'électricité si on a
l'hydroélectricité ou si on a le
nucléaire ou si on a bien développer les
énergies renouvelables c'est le cas de
la france on peut avoir un prix
d'électricité - d'enfer énergies
renouvelables c'est pas vraiment très
très
hot aujourd'hui en france ben ça a bien
démarré et moi j'ai été longtemps élu du
département de la savoie où on avait
créé les premiers panneaux solaires et
on avait le commissariat à l'énergie
atomique qui avait créé l'institut
national du solaire
mais à force de ne pas dire vraiment la
vérité aux français
c'est à dire leur dire que on réussira
pas la transition écologique si on sait
pas faire des efforts et changer nos
modes de vie y compris en acceptant que
parfois il ya des éoliennes et des
éoliennes offshore que parfois il ya des
panneaux solaires et elle que même les
les chansonnettes
considèrent qu'ils ont du mal à accepter
l'implantation dans certaines zones oui
c'est toute la difficulté
le giec cria l'urgence et il a raison et
ça fait déjà des années qu'on nous dit
qu'il ya urgence à lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique et pour autant
on sait pas prendre des décisions qui
s'imposent en matière de nucléaire en
matière d'éolien en matière de solaire
en matière d'hydroélectricité je veux
juste rappeler quelque chose que tu es
un événement dramatique ya quelques
années le dans les moments où le
gouvernement de françois hollande avait
décidé l'arrêt de la centrale de
fessenheim
qui avaient aimé est validée est actée
par lui même avait évidemment puisque de
toute façon lorsque vous décidez l'arrêt
d'une centrale de y'a pas d'autres choix
il n'y a pas de retour en arrière
possible il ya eu cet immense drame vous
savez de deux garçons qui a été tuée au
barrage de sivens et donc ça aussi
arrêter les investissements
hydroélectrique et puis quelques années
après on a considéré qu'il fallait pas
faire de champ solaire et puis quelques
années après qu'il fallait se méfier
d'hydrogène et puis quelques années
après que il faut pas faire d owlient ça
fait combien d'années de retard 22 ans
qu'au fond c'est probablement une
dizaine d'années de retard que nous
avons pris c'est à dire que désormais il
ya urgence à accélérer ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui un certain nombre de
centrales nucléaires s'est pratiquement
en voie d'achèvement je n'ai pas pris
c'est disons oui c'est exactement ça et
donc qu'est-ce que ça signifie sur le
plan du débat public
ça signifie que si on se met pas
d'accord sur un constat si on partage
pas les constats derrière on n'est pas
capable d'expliquer aux français qu'il
ya des solutions et qu'elles peuvent
aussi à l'artère avant de parler
justement d'évolution des bobs pic et ce
qui en découle du cnr conseil national
de refonder sion 2-3 questions
techniques cinquante ans après après 73
le contexte on parle de la crise de 73
le contexte politique et géopolitique a
changé est ce que cette crise
énergétique est surmontable où elle est
insurmontable à quelles conditions
étaient surmontables et puis autre
question qui les lie à ça
c'est par la dette aujourd'hui qu'on
fait payer l'augmentation des prix de
l'énergie ce que c'est un choix j'ai un
choix judicieux
alors est ce qu'elle est surmontable
tout cas on va tout faire dans quelles
conditions moi je regrettais de la
polémique un peu inutile et un peu
stérile sur le conseil de défense de
l'énergie qui a organisé le prénom n'a
révélé qu'il est encore heureux dans un
pays démocratique le programme public
puisse organiser comme il veut en étant
sérieux
de parler de ces débats de débattre de
ces sujets dans le cadre d'un conseil de
défense mais ça sert à faire du pilotage
entre toutes celles et ceux qui doivent
prendre des décisions pour répondre à
votre question c'est à dire comment on
va passer l'hiver prochain on le fera
d'abord parce que la meilleure énergie
c'est celle qu'on ne dépense pas donc on
va le faire à travers des économies
d'énergie et c'est chaque français et
chaque entreprise qui effectivement va
faire des efforts on va essayer de
modifier un peu son mode de vie et que
si chacun essaye de restreindre un peu
sa consommation énergétique on puisse
passer 100 black out le l'hiver prochain
et puis ensuite
vous me posez une deuxième question
c'est est ce que c'est c'est bien de le
faire en touchant à l'argent public
j'ai beaucoup écouté ses croyances sur
les champs relations futures oui le
paiement de cette dette et si l'économie
s'effondre
du jour au lendemain et qu'il faut la
reconstruire un risque ça coûtera encore
plus fermé ya risque regardez
aujourd'hui vous avez en angleterre un
peuple qui est en train de se révolter
et de brûler ses factures d'électricité
vous avez en italie des entreprises qui
menacent de s'arrêter qui travaillent
par intermittence parce que l'énergie
est trop cher ça coûte en réalité
beaucoup plus cher aux contribuables
aujourd'hui et ça coûtera plus cher aux
contribuables demain que d'arrêter des
pans entiers de l'économie donc et donc
il faut pouvoir soutenir par l'argent
public aujourd'hui en le ciblant
évidemment mais il faut pouvoir par
l'argent public rendre
j'allais dire accepter avant tout cas
moins douloureux pour la population la
situation qu'on traverse et faire en
sorte que l'économie puisse continuer de
tourner moi je veux bien
toutes les leçons du monde de la part
des républicains
qui nous explique qu'il faut retrouver
un équilibre dans les dépenses publiques
qu'on dépense beaucoup trop la seule
chose qu'ils ont été capables de
proposer lors de la loi sur le pouvoir
d'achat c'était que sur subventionne
plus encore le carburant on est tous
contents de payer le carburant 1 euro 50
au lieu de 2 euros depuis trois jours
car c'est une décision scène qui a été
prise par le gouvernement mais aussi par
une large majorité à l'assemblée et je
m'en réjouis mais on peut pas vouloir
une chose et n'inverse et parce qu'on
est dans l'opposition a appelé à l'
équilibre des finances publiques tout en
étant pousse au crime pour dépenser
toujours plus en ce moment justement
alors avant de parler du cnr va en
parler d'abord le budget puisque ça va
être le débat apportant de cette rentrée
en tout cas de l'automne nous sommes à
trois semaines de la présentation du
budget ont concédé miss la droite vous
en avez parlé réclament des économies la
gauche peut taxer les riches et les
super profits sur quoi la majorité
serait-elle prête à céder est ce qu'un
compromis par exemple sur la taxation
des supers profits est envisageable avec
la nuque c'est avec les autres partis de
l'opposition mais oui frédéric haziza la
façon même dont vous le formuler montre
qui a encore de grands progrès
démocratique à faire dans ce pays c'est
à dire c'est pas céder c'est comment on
trouve des compromis moi je pense que ce
budget il doit effectivement nous
ramener sur des trajectoires financières
qui sont équilibrées parce que on va pas
rajouter une dette financière la dette
écologique qu'on a déjà accumulé depuis
des décennies évidemment et tout le
monde est d'accord là dessus mais ce
budget il a pour objectif que notre
police fonctionne mieux pour lutter
contre la sécurité dans le pays dont il
a pour objectif de continuer à augmenter
le budget de la justice que l'école la
santé puissent disposer de moyens leur
permettant de répondre de ce noeud se
remettre en fonctionnement on s'est
tellement inquiété lors de la rentrée
parce qu'on avait on a beaucoup de
chauffeurs de bus dans les bus scolaires
et qu'on risquait de ne plus avoir
d'enseignants devant les élèves alors
tout ça c'est une réflexion approfondie
qui doit être mené sur chacun de ces
secteurs c'est pour ça quand on ouvre
les chantiers à nouveau aujourd'hui mais
d'abord on fait un budget pour le pays
on a essayé pas de trouver la manière de
s'attirer les uns les autres dans des
guet-apens savoir quel compromis
possible quel consensus possible
notamment avec les oppositions qui soit
qu'elle soit de gauche de droite
éventuellement d extrême gauche moi je
vais vous dire est ce que c'est parce
que
je suis pas très optimiste ah bon j'ai
lu ce matin vous n'êtes pas très
d'obtenir sûr que l'évolution du débat
autour du bus stationné sur la capacité
à vouloir gouverner ensemble parce que
vous pensez des kits de l air les
français au fond tous tous parce que
voilà que ce soit le la grande
usurpation de la nuque ps ou le la
grande dissimulation du front national
de toute façon à l'assemblée nationale
il ya déjà beaucoup de personnes qui ont
pas envie de travailler avec le
gouvernement mais au-delà de ça les
français ont envoyé à l'assemblée
nationale au fond une assemblée très
représentatif de toutes les sensibilités
du pays
c'est quasiment la proportionnelle sauf
que malheureusement c'est une assemblée
qui est qui a été
kemal n'est peut-être parce que s'il
avait été élu à la proportionnelle
chacun se serait fait lire sur ces idées
plutôt que contre celle des autres elle
était élue au scrutin majoritaire et
donc pendant un résultat c'est un large
panel de toutes les sensibilités du pays
soit ce que chacune et chacun des
parlementaires sont persuadés d'avoir
été élu pour voter contre les auteurs
que vous êtes pessimiste et donc
je sais que gabriella talent
ne veut pas se résoudre à utiliser
larmes du 49-3 qui apparaîtrait comme
une forme de brutalité démocratique
volige quoi moi ce que je pense
aujourd'hui c'est que nous avons
quelques semaines devant nous pour
regarder si les oppositions trois
semaines dans les trois semaines qui
viennent il faut que les oppositions
nous dise si elles resteront dans les
postures et considérant qu'elles sont
dans l'opposition votre ont
naturellement nécessairement quelles que
soient nos propositions contre le budget
ou est-ce qu'elles sont capables de
faire des propositions moi je les
appelle à faire des propositions pensé
quoi sera possible est-ce que c'est à
dire on veut un peu je vous disais que
j'étais pessimiste mais justement je
posais la question autrement on a vu que
sa puce
ce2 relais de cette manière dans le
cadre du du correctif collectif
budgétaire de cet été - est-ce que au
moment du budget s'apprête pareil je
pense que ça va être difficile avec
les républicains qui joue la compétition
de leur future présidence et chacun des
candidats a d'ores et déjà annoncé que
de toute façon il faudrait voter contre
le budget c'est à dire avant même de
voir le budget on veut voter contre le
budget on sait que le lan ubs est
intégralement dans la main de jean luc
mélenchon qui n'a aucune intention de
voter le budget non plus et le
rassemblement national ne fera
évidemment pas ce cadeau non plus même
si désormais il se cache derrière dans
l'art est donc ma crainte c'est que la
france dans trois semaines face le
constat qu'on pourra peut-être pas avoir
de budget c'est vous dire à quel parti
trop vite dans ses comptes médias
immédiat et dans ces conditions je pense
que la sagesse c'est de demander aux
oppositions ce que son nom pas leur
position leur posture mais leurs
propositions
il faut qu'aujourd'hui elle énonce des
ça n'est pas encore le cas vous citez
les républicains avec avec les finances
publiques on a vu qu'il pouvait dire une
chose et la verse dans la même minute
l'été dernier puis ce qu'ils appelaient
à l' équilibre des finances publiques et
en même temps à la dépense publique
quant à la gauche sur la taxation des
supers profits
objectivement
on a essayé de bien
dans la majorité on a essayé de bâtir
une position de sagesse
il ya effectivement des profits
exceptionnels qui sont consécutifs en
particulier chez les énergéticiens à la
crise de l'énergie laquelle on faisait
référence tout à l'heure
nous leur avons demandé via des fonds
d'investissements qu'elle puisse
investir dans une accélération de la
transition écologique et au fond que des
énergéticiens participe à la transition
énergétique il n'y a rien de choquant
moi je veux bien que l'on considère que
l'état doit tout et peut tout mais
pourquoi prélever de l'argent pour
ensuite le réinvestir quand ils peuvent
investir directement
regardez ce qu'a fait cma-cgm en
investissant dans l'air france en
investissant dans gefco qui sont là
aussi des fleurons qui demain pourront
participer à la transition écologique
moi je préfère que ces profits
exceptionnels qui ont été engrangés par
des entreprises soient investis dans
l'économie réelle créer des emplois et
permettre la toile et s'ils ne le font
pas et c'est là la sagesse de mission et
s'ils ne le font pas on se garde la
possibilité il était effectivement les
taxer
j'avais fait une proposition assez
simple parce que faut pas oublier vous
étiez député paul oui c'est ça mais
qu'ils aient repris désormais par par
mes amis du mouvement démocrate à
l'assemblée
c'était d'avoir
un yes minimale un impôt société
minimale parce que faut pas oublier
qu'aujourd'hui et d'un port aujourd'hui
on parle beaucoup de des bénéfices des
entreprises mais faut pas avoir une
mémoire de poisson rouge quand une
entreprise fait des bénéfices elles
payent des impôts déjà
25% sur son bénéfice donc lui le
bénéfice sera élevé plus de toute façon
elles payeront des impôts et moi je les
fais une proposition c'est que toutes
les entreprises de france paye agnès
minimal c'est la proposition de joe
biden qui a été reprise effectivement
comme vous le dites à l'échelle de
l'union européenne si demain toutes les
entreprises de france avait un ace
plancher c'est à dire que l'optimisation
fiscale ne permettait pas de descendre
en dessous de 15% ce à peu près la barre
ça qu'elles les dirigeants du monde
pourrait se mettre d'accord aujourd'hui
elle des chances d'aboutir et bien à ce
moment là c'est même pas la peine
d'aller chercher une taxation des supers
ce modèle
nous leur proposons cette année comme
nous l'avions proposé les deux années
précédentes et
il ya je pense des chances que ce soit
adopter s'il ya une bonne coordination
européenne c'est à l'échelon européen
évidemment qu'il faut décider de ce type
de mesure puisque il n'est pas question
d'introduire des formes de concurrence
fiscale entre les pays on sait bien la
difficulté qui peut être la nôtre avec
un certain nombre de six noms paradis
fiscaux en tout cas de différenciation
fiscal par exemple avec l'irlande donc
si demain nous pouvions déjà avoir un
impôt sociétés fixé à 15% comme les
états unis s'apprêtent à le faire n'en
discuterait plus de la taxation des
supers profits on aurait regret de la
justice fiscale et donc sur le budget le
49 3 il est inévitable
c'est une question non non il est
évidemment pas inévitable et si vous
la sagesse et ses doit être au début du
débat ou plus non il faut que le délit d
un peu plus tard moi je crois qu'il faut
qu'on l'assumé c'est à dire qu'il faut
qu'on assume de se dire voilà assurément
possible il faut que vous êtes souligner
le 40e 3 nous nous trouvons il faut que
l'ensemble des députés toutes tendances
politiques confondues
assume
qu'en cas de blocage
ça conduira nécessairement aux 49 3
parce qu'on peut pas laisser la france
sans budget et caen et donc qu'ils
assument
de faire des propositions et que l'on
considère pas comme incongru
quand on est dans l'opposition de faire
progresser un budget et se donner ainsi
les moyens de le voter c'est un
changement fondamental parce que comme
auparavant il y avait toujours des
majorité absolue à l'assemblée nationale
on partait du principe qu'on pouvait
faire n'importe quoi lors des séances
budgétaire quand on était dans
l'opposition et qu'à la fin quoi qu'il
arrive parce qu'on était dans
l'opposition il faudrait voter contre et
là là il n'ya plus de majorité absolue
et donc les oppositions ont la
possibilité de co construire ont la
possibilité de gouverner vous les
invitez justement moi je les invite à
essayer de coco gouverner la france
parce qu en somme on a besoin de toutes
les énergies et alors je vous reposer
que sur 140 autres s'ils devaient être
utilisent ce serait en début de débat au
plus tard
mais j'ai de toute façon il est déjà
dans le débat chacun mais ça il faudrait
attirante le débat dès le départ et
proposé la question était simple est ce
que la france peut rester sans budget en
2023 qui sera une année vous l'avez dit
vous-même tout à l'heure l'année de tous
les dangers non ça n'est pas possible et
donc il faut que dans les trois semaines
qui viennent nous trouvions les
possibilités de compromis et s'il n'y a
pas de possibilité de compromis il
faudra assumer la responsabilité et vous
savez au fond s'il est dépassé c'est
plus simple sur un texte budgétaire
passer un texte de loi au 49 3 ya
effectivement une forme de brutalité
démocratique sur un texte budgétaire et
à utiliser la menace sinon
l'accomplissement d'un 49 3 c'est
effectivement beaucoup moins là c'est ce
qui permet aux contrats de ne pas
brutaliser les français parce qu'ils
auraient pu de budget alors l'inflation
avec le niveau élevé de l'inflation donc
aux alentours de 6% postes en france je
crois ne doit pas conduire il met même à
croire voir la doctrine qu'il a exprimée
pendant la campagne présidentielle en
clair est-ce qu'il faut indexer les
salaires sur l'inflation est-ce que
c'est pas inévitable
et vous avez des chefs d'entreprise vous
savez ce que je vais vous je vais vous
donner un
avis qui est très personnel sur le sujet
mais que le mouvement démocrate a
beaucoup défendu au cours des dernières
années et moi je crois que les salaires
sont pas assez élevés dans notre pays
ils se demandent comment et donc
la possibilité de les augmenter
la plus
la plus sûre la moins risquée pour les
entreprises c'est de le faire à travers
la participation et l'intéressement
c'est à dire qu'à chaque fois qu'une
entreprise fait des bénéfices elle les
partage mieux avec ses salariés 17 puis
des dizaines
si ça marche
ça marche ça marche seulement pour 11 3
% des salariés si 100 % des salariés
demain avait un meilleur partage des
bénéfices c'est à dire qu'à chaque fois
qu'une entreprise fait des bénéfices à
chaque fois que l a la possibilité de
verser des dividendes à ses actionnaires
elle verse aussi un salaire variable à
ses salariés on augmente les salaires ce
que vous savez aujourd'hui tout le monde
cherche dans le bâtiment dans
l'hôtellerie dans la restauration dans
l'informatique dans l'aide à la personne
les personnes âgées les personnes
handicapées on parlait des chauffeurs de
bus tout à l'heure
et donc on pourrait d'un revers de main
expliqué que c'est parce que les gens
sont tous des feignants et que on a un
système social parce que les salaires
sont les patrons générerait mais il faut
peut-être se demander aussi pour ceux de
savoir si le si le travail est
suffisamment rémunérés dans notre pays
commencée dans les années mais il a
répondu rien et parce que dans ce pays
on attend tout l'état et moi je crois
beaucoup au dialogue social parce que
vous joueriez ans que dans chaque
secteur d'activité il ya des conventions
collectives qui mériterait d'être revu à
la hausse et je crois que partout où il
ya une fragilité et où les entrepreneurs
se dire demain
attention si j'augmente tous les stades
sous les salaires trop brutalement je
vais moi même nourrir un peu d'inflation
et donc demain faudra encore je la
répercutent sur mépris et puis il peut y
avoir un retournement de tendance si on
peut se retrouver dans une grave crise
en 2023/2024 donc j'ai du mal à le faire
mais en revanche si on leur donne la
possibilité de le faire sur la base du
bénéfice réalisé
et si demain on peut se dire que
finalement on peut aller chercher un
treizième mois si on a bien travaillé
dans son entreprise parce qu'en
travaillant bien dans son entreprise on
travaille bien aussi pour son pays et
que ce pays aujourd'hui il a besoin de
retrouver de la croissance pour faire
face aux grands défis qui viennent
dans change aussi la nature des
relations sociales relations sociales
relations politiques débat politique
le parlement et la rue ya des appels à
la rouille du côté de la france assure
mise du côté de la nuque est ce un
procès en illégitimité de dumas prend
bâtard de hollande comme a pu le dire
françois hory fin au printemps des
prises de position en retrait sur la
laïcité on nous dit pour plaire à une
partie de l'électorat des banlieues est
ce à dire que la france est soumise joue
sciemment avec le feu à des fins
politiques
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure que face à
toutes les grandes crises que nous
avions à affronter
le pays peut être en difficulté
il a besoin de
d'une grande mobilisation nationale
mais je crois pas qu'ils puissent être
bousculé sur ses fondements
ce que vous venez d'évoquer sa
effectivement c'est un risque pour la
démocratie c'est à dire c'est à dire que
dans le débat public aujourd'hui
où on n'est pas capable de se mettre
d'accord sur
ce qui se passe en ukraine qui est
l'agresseur et qui est l'agressé on le
voit tous les jours on parle longueur de
plateau télé en matière de crise
énergétique ce qu'il est nécessaire de
faire là où il est nécessaire d'investir
en matière économique
on reste figé dans des postures plutôt
qu'être dans des solutions
les postures souvent 13 idéologique à
force de ne pas se poser les bonnes
questions et de faire un peu de
désinformation je pense qu'on peut saper
les fondements de la démocratie qu'est
ce qui se joue aujourd'hui
en ukraine sept exactement notre modèle
de société notre modèle de société
démocratique qui est attaqué par
l'agresseur russe
en matière
de laïcité
tous les jours on voit à quel point un
des piliers de la démocratie peut être
remis en cause parfois effectivement
dans une optique de calcul électoral ou
simplement parce qu'on maîtrise assez
mal les conseils dans et donc nous avons
besoin aujourd'hui de
jeu c'est à dire se remette les yeux en
face des trous et donc d'objectiver le
débat pour défendre la démocratie en se
mettant d'accord sur des réalités et des
ja d'île ya trop de personnes
aujourd'hui ils font de la
désinformation
alors justement il jusqu'à jusqu'à sap
et ça nous conduit à l'actualité macro
nice en 2010 7 centimes acronis tu
viceira depuis soutient mélenchon à la
présidentielle de l'année ps aux
législatives
elle relaie désormais les théories
complotistes de poutine je vous parle du
pied de ségolène royal qu'est-ce que
vous inspire en tout cas l'évolution de
ségolène royal c'est déjà la déclaration
sur l'ukraine
a parlé de crimes de guerre notamment à
bout de chats et la maternité de
marioupol moi j'ai été comme tous ceux
qui l'ont entendu évidemment le choqué
par ses propos
qui sont d'ailleurs
qui sont au fond pathétique mais
arrêtons-nous un instant sur ce que ça
signifie qu est ce que ça révèle du
débat public aujourd'hui un certain
nombre de personnes se comportent en
d'influenceurs
faire un peu comme dans le monde
économique et des influenceurs pour
essayer de vendre des jouets aux enfants
ou des divisions je vous faire préciser
votre père marc furrer c'est à dire
comme disait jean l'étranger des agents
de poutine réponse de converser royal
des personnes qui sont en tout cas
manipuler j'espère qu'elles ne sont pas
à pointer mais en tout cas un certain
nombre de gens qui court les plateaux
télé qui peuvent faire des articles de
presse sans d'ailleurs que on leur fasse
quelques procès que ce soit et on l'a vu
par la presse comme une suite bien sûr
et au fond chacun s'arrange avec la
vérité et essayent d'influencer
l'opinion publique en manipulant les
faits c'est royal donc royal le cas
royal qu'est ce que vous en pensez paye
mais on est on est exactement dans une
illustration de ce type mais madame
royal a été candidate à la
présidentielle donc elle est un peu plus
connu que les autres mais tous les jours
dans tous les journaux et sur toutes les
chaînes de télévision continue vous
voyez passer un certain nombre de gens
qui disent exactement l'inversé de la
réalité et quand tu comptes en suisse et
dans une société du complot dit dans le
débat public on n'est pas capable de se
mettre d'accord allez je dit pas la
vérité parce que la vérité peut toujours
faire l'objet de
deux débats d'opinion mais en tout cas
de constat partagé si on n'est pas
capable de dire qu en ukraine il ya un
agresseur et un agressé et que celui qui
agresse agressent au fond notre modèle
de société notre modèle de civilisation
je crois que là on rende sous le coup
d'une phrase une phrase de jean claude
gayssot c'est quand il a fait voter sa
loi de 1986 c'est disait le le racisme
n'est pas une opinion c'est un délit jeu
le mensonge peut pas non plus être
érigée en opinion dans la démocratie et
je crois que la démocratie française a
besoin de se solidifier de se renforcer
en remettre un peu de parler au soleil
du mensonge oui évidemment
et alors autre question puisqu'on parle
un peu de politique que vous inspire la
bataille pour la présence de l'ère eric
ciotti candidat à présidence de ce parti
soutient la candidature de laurent
wauquiez à la présidentielle qu'est ce
que j'en pensais pas ce que vous
connaissez aussi vous qui vous avez
travaillé lecture et la région rhône
alpes je trouve très bien que se joue
démocratiquement les présidences des
partis et je pourrais dire quoi que ce
soit d'ailleurs sur les mérites comparés
des uns et des autres je n'ai toujours
pas compris depuis plus de cinq ans
maintenant qu'elle était en réalité le
positionnement politique
les véritables orientations de l air que
ce soit sur l'europe soit sur l'économie
libérale ou pas libéral que ce soit en
matière sociale que ce soit en matière
écologique ce parti est malheureusement
devenue inaudible ce qui me gêne c'est
que l'un des candidats vous avez cité
eric ciotti aujourd'hui ce soit déjà
projeté dans l'élection présidentielle
comme s'il n'allait rien se passer
pendant cinq ans
et celle ci aussi dans la majorité avec
trois candidats potentiels le maire
philippe da manha mais un mois je qu'il
jette sur la succession de mme auger
tous les jours vous avez rappelé que
désormais j'étais pu débuter et donc
comme porte parole du modem j'ai toute
ma liberté de parole moi j'appelle mes
amis au sein de la majorité comme mes
adversaires dans l'opposition a pas se
projeter en 2027 c'est d'une insulte
faite aux français
il ya devant nous
le les plus extraordinaires défis les
plus grands enjeux réussir la transition
climatique ce en faisant en sorte
qu'elles soient socialement acceptable
pour les français
résister alors que la guerre est revenu
sur le sol européen et qu'on sera sans
doute dans une guerre longue être
capable de relancer l'économie sur le
terrain retrouvé réindustrialiser ré
intéresser les gens au travail les
ramener vers le travail à la fois les
inciter à travailler mais aussi mieux
les récompenses et mieux récompenser
leur mairie tout ça c'est des enjeux
pour la semaine prochaine on va pas
attendre cinq ans avant de faire des
propositions de régler les 3 éléphants
avant en avoir de la semaine prochaine
justement par la semaine prochaine
justement la semaine prochaine dans
l'actualité de lancement jeudi 8
septembre la semaine prochaine du
conseil national de la refondation ou
cnr dont françois bayrou sera le
secrétaire général le patron mais elle
reste en tout cas le patron derrière
macro reste que les oppositions y
compris le président du sénat gérard
larcher ne veulent pas en entendre
parler de ce séminaire est ce que ça
peut dire que c'est un projet mort-né et
puis à quoi ça va servir et cette voix
servir
il faut il faut qu'on précise d'ailleurs
que au départ bayrou il n'était pas très
très partants pour ce cr il avait des
réserves mais vous avez vous avez des
réserves dans les oppositions il faut le
dire il ya des réserves aussi dans la
majorité
moi je vais vous dire je trouvais leur
leadership qui sera pas je trouve que
c'est une excellente idée
d'abord parce que d'avoir un lieu où
le gouvernement le parlement mais aussi
les élus locaux et les corps
intermédiaires peuvent se retrouver et
se parler c'est souvent ce qui nous a
manqué depuis cinq ans alors on a pêché
peut-être parfois
par l'esprit d'urgence on a voulu aller
très vite sur certaines réformes dans
les cinq ans qui viennent de s'écouler
mais il nous a été régulièrement
reproché de pas suffisamment entendre
discuter négocier
modifié parfois une décision en
discutant avec les corps intermédiaires
le président de la république propose
que les corps intermédiaires toutes les
forces vives du pays puissent se
retrouver ça n'abîme en rien les
institutions la loi se fera même
nationale vote à l'assemblée nationale
ayant les oppositions de vous dise nous
disons ne sera pas président moi j'ai
amélioré les syndicats ils seront prêts
justement ce qui est logique parce que
les syndicats ont une culture du
dialogue m donc même s'ils peuvent avoir
la crainte d'être
instrumentalisés parce qu'on voit bien
ce qui est derrière tout ça on veut pas
venir dans le nouveau machin inventé par
le président de la république parce que
on craindrait tout d'un coup de devenir
mercredi ce maquereau nice mais
contagieux mais pas à ce point là c'est
moi je crois que le président de la
république a tiré les enseignements des
cinq années qui viennent de s'écouler
qui avait été très dur on a mené des
trains de réformes tambour battant
pendant trois ans et ensuite et on en
voit les résultats économiques
aujourd'hui avec un chômage qui a jamais
été aussi bas ensuite on a été touché
par deux immenses crise celle du covan
et ensuite celle de l'ukraine
sur les cinq années qui viennent de
s'écouler le président de la république
a considéré et il s'y était engagé
pendant la campagne présidentielle qu'il
fallait changer de méthode la méthode ça
compte en politique le respect des
interlocuteurs ça compte avec la
question c'est moi je ne sais comment le
résident du sénat après avoir réclamé
cinq ans durant qu'on parle plus avec le
sénat et qu'on parle plus avec les élus
locaux refusent de venir et que les
associations d'élus locaux refusent de
venir aussi
rassurons les mois je j'ai bien compris
qu'ils n'étaient pas convaincus une fois
l bayrou se montre convaincant pour que
ils reviennent autour de la mer va leur
dire quand on crée une valeur de
recovery aux rayons le je crois que
françois bayrou est en capacité de
leur garantir
qu'ils ne seront pas instrumentaliser
c'est pas parce que vous venez discuter
avec emmanuel macron que vous de
maquereaux nist ça peut arriver ça m'est
arrivé d'ailleurs par le passé mais et
je m'interroge parfois sur sur la façon
de fonctionner notre vie publique
parce que vous feriez le budget parce
que vous feriez une loi parce que vous
acceptez de venir discuter tout d'un
coup du jour au lendemain vous seriez de
taxes et d'intelligence avec le pouvoir
dont le la véritable intelligence dans
le meilleur sens du terme c'est de
travailler avec les autres et pour moi
c'est c'est parfaitement
incompréhensible parce que
il ya celui à ce sujet de concertation
on nous la réclame beaucoup au moment où
la mer en place finalement ils viennent
pas autour de la table et puis après est
ce que certains veulent bien est ce que
vous disiez
je le crois absolument pas parce que de
toute façon
on peut avoir une réserve peut-être sur
sa dénomination je lui réserve là dessus
c'est vrai qu' il peut y avoir peut-être
une espèce de confusion sémantique les
voilà sur le cnr conseil national de la
résistance qui était au fond un projet
de un projet de reconstruction alors que
là c'est plus un projet où on va essayer
de partager les constats et de revenir
sur le lait sujet je vous interromps pu
vous parler de royal oui parce que
le deuxième sujet de du conseil national
de la refondation
c'est justement d'essayer de définir
ensemble les problématiques se mettent
d'accord sur les constats on peut pas
avoir dans le débat public des gens qui
prétendent qu'il ya trois millions de
chômeurs et donc il ya d'autres à 8
millions de chômeurs celle ci s'est
mélangé voilà c'est à peu près comme
l'augmentation du smic pendant la
campagne législative chaque semaine le
smi prenait sent le gros relais à 9,22
mélangeant voilà et maintenant donc on
augmente indéfiniment prenez le sujet
de l'énergie on a parlé du nucléaire par
un moment on se met d'accord sur ce
qu'est la consommation annuelle de la
france si demain on veut arrêter les
hydrocarbures est donc une fois qu'on
s'est mis d'accord sur ces constats ça
permet d'avancer ensemble et d'éviter
d'avoir à longueur de discours des gens
qui nous explique on va pouvoir tout
faire sur le nucléaire mais c'est la
même chose sur la réforme des retraites
alors justement je vais vous poser cette
question justement je vais vous poser la
question l'année prochaine nous allons
franchir la barre des 3000 milliards
d'euros de dette la solution pour sortir
bas de cette spirale infernale de la
dette c'est quoi c'est plus de travail
ou plus un pot aux roses est bien c'est
que dans un espace c'est donc plus qu'en
mai lanouf et comme le conseil national
de la refondation
on se met d'accord sur les chiffres moi
j'ai été très choquée lorsque j'étais
parlementaire de voir le conseil
d'orientation des retraites expliquer
tous les six mois que les comptes
étaient déséquilibrées puis finalement
été rééquilibrée et puis
s'il est dit et on attend à ce qu un
jour peut-être mais parce que c'est un
art difficile je dirais pas une critique
ça dépend du grand direct et ça dépend
des contextes et des projections
économiques mais si le système des
retraites on le prend par le biais
uniquement des finances publiques parce
qu'en france on dépense 13% du pib sur
les retraites alors que dans tous les
autres pays de l' ocde on dépense entre
8 et 10
on trouvera pas la solution avec la
représentation syndicale si en revanche
on regarde les deux sujets majeurs
sur l'âge de la retraite c'est à dire
l'emploi des seniors comment on parvient
à travailler plus longtemps dans notre
pays en france on travaille en moyenne
jusque 60 ans et demi alors que dans
tous les autres pays européens on
travaille en moyenne jusqu'à 62 ans et
demi il ya deux ans d'écart on n'est pas
en train de parler de la retraite à 67
ans pourquoi il ya deux ans d'écart
parce qu'on sait pas inciter les
entreprises à conserver les seniors et
quand on s'est pas montrée aux seniors
que parfois on travaille en six mois de
plus ou une année de plus ils vont
gagner un pourcentage supplémentaire de
retraite mais dampha son deuxième sujet
sur la pénibilité sur se met pas
d'accord sur la pénibilité sur ce
qu'elle est comment on la qualifie
comment la rémunère et comment
éventuellement on part plus tôt à la
retraite parce qu'on a eu un travail
plus pénible toute sa vie ou pendant une
partie de sa vie mais forcément on peut
pas s'accorder si vous réfléchissez pas
avec tous sur le travail c'est même pas
la peine d'ouvrir le sujet des retraites
la réforme des retraites comment vous
l'envisagez selon quels critères et puis
selon quel calendrier mais moi je pense
que le grand enjeu du débat public
aujourd'hui ce serait de parler du
travail
nous avons besoin que notre pays
travaillent plus mais j'ai l'habitude de
dire c'est quand on voit parfois tous
cas l'air de craquer à l'école dans la
police dans la justice ou à l'hôpital
au fond moi je
pourrais peut-être accepter de
travailler une année ou deux années de
plus dans la vie ou de travail aient ou
non une heure ou deux heures de plus
dans ma semaine moi je fais pas un
métier pénible mais simplement pour que
tout ça ne craque plus que la france ait
les moyens cette nation
c'est d'abord d'abord réfléchir au
travail parce que si vous commencez par
l'âge et si vous dites comme ça de but
en blanc finalement le bon équilibre ses
soixante trois ans et demi d'abord ça
relève à peu près d'un art divinatoire
parce que quel que soit quelle sera la
situation économique de la france dans
dix ans quel aurait été son niveau de
croissance de chaque année des dix
années qui viennent pour savoir si ces
63.4 63,7 le bon âge déquilibre ça ça
correspond à peu près à rien c'est
quasiment de l'idéologie si en revanche
vous réfléchissez d'abord au travail
qu'est ce qui peut donner envie de plus
travailler aujourd'hui et qu'est ce qui
peut donner envie de travailler plus
longtemps et d'avoir la possibilité de
travailler venant donc travailler sur
l'employabilité et ayant travaillé sur
la transmission des compétences quand on
arrive en fin de carrière travailler un
peu moins et transmettre un peu plus aux
traîtres sera fait avant la fin du
quinquennat et mises en oeuvre
je pense que c'est une obligation
absolue pas par idéologie mais parce que
nous avons besoin d'inaugurer un nouveau
rapport au travail dans notre pays alors
si on réfléchit pas à la façon de
travailler vous avez vu l'évolution du
télétravail les attentes des français
qui sont complètement différentes dans
leur approche les tous les français qui
ont démissionné de leur travail pour
aller vers un autre travail qu'il est
qui les anime conséquent il enthousiasme
le plus mais bien sûr alors c'est ça
qu'il faut prendre en compte et je
trouve que au fond on fait un raccourci
délétère lorsqu'on veut parler de la
réforme de l'assurance chômage ou de la
réforme des retraites sans parler du
rapport au travail et votre débat autre
débat ces débats autour des institutions
le modem où vous en êtes le
vice-président et le porte parole n'a
déposé dans le cadre de sa niche
parlementaire du 10 octobre ce sera la
première niche parlementaire de la
session on va proposer une proposition
va déposer nous positionnons instituant
la proportionnelle aux législatives
pourquoi et comment et selon quelles
modalités pour professionnels
alors d'abord parce que de tous les
engagements que nous avions pris que le
président de la république en 2017 il y
en a deux compacts et réalisait réforme
des retraites on vient d'en parler et la
réforme des institutions pour les
raisons conseil s'est arrêtée en cours
de route
on a besoin
de très vite faire une réforme
institutionnelle ça va paraître bizarre
parce que chaque fois conduit vont faire
des réformes nationales ont vu benoît
c'est pas le moment pour attendent ya
quand même beaucoup d'autres priorités
et c'est vrai que les priorités sont
nombreuses et immense mais il ya une
réalité c'est qu'on ne peut faire de
réformes institutionnelles que au
lendemain des élections si vous attendez
deux ou trois ans vous êtes déjà dans le
scrutin suilhard fonctionnel et plus
personne ne veut faire pour fonctionner
et la proportionnelle aujourd'hui vous
avez une assemblée qui ressemblerait à
une assemblée issue de scrutin
proportionnel pourquoi elle n'arrive pas
à fonctionner ou qu'en tout cas elle ne
fonctionne que entre les vociférations
de l'extrême droite et de l'extrême
gauche et les autres sont au spectacle
et les français devant un spectacle
désolant scrutin ben c'est parce que
toutes ces personnes ont été désignées
dans un affrontement est alors donc
alors que dans une seule tête dans un
scrutin proportionnel qu'on se le dise
bien il faudrait quasi d'adieu je
m'arrête un instant là dessus dans un
scrutin proportionnel
chaque sensibilité politique est
représenté et présente son projet sa
sensibilité ses convictions ses valeurs
ses propositions et donc elles passent
moins de temps à critiquer les autres ou
à vouloir abattre les autres que à
défendre ce à quoi précisément qu'est ce
qui va avoir dans votre premier en
revanche elle cède avance qu'une fois
arrivée à l'assemblée y aura pas de
majorité qui se dégagera et qu'il faudra
nécessairement composer qu'est-ce qu'il
retrouvait des conflits sociaux du 10
octobre et donc il y aura le scrutin de
1985 pour nous c'est à dire le scrutin
mitterrand qui avait été qui avait
fonctionné en 90 prochain scrutin
proportionnel départemental avec seuils
d'attribution à 5% donc je les trie
vision de minimum pour avoir un député
c'est 5 % exactement et donc combien de
députés par département et du minimum
pour garder le même nombre de députés
est qu'aujourd'hui et veiller à ce que
le les départements chaque département
est évidemment un parlementaire comme
celle ci aujourd'hui vous pensez que
cette proposition doit des chances
d'être adopté c'est là qu'on va voir si
les oppositions
sont seulement dans les postures les
impostures ou si
elles ont un peu de suite dans les idées
mais est ce que parce que que je sache
la france insoumise le rassemblement
national
les écologistes et une partie des
socialistes ont tous pris position en
faveur du sco d'un portail à la majorité
est ce que oui même ma grand à propos de
provisions et genre alors je ne le sais
pas je ne le sais pas mais je suis sûr
d'une chose c'est qu'il y avait dans le
programme du président de la république
le fait d'un stylet de la
proportionnelle dans nos modes de
scrutin et je sais surtout une chose
c'est que on peut pas laisser on peut
pas rester les bras ballants aux
élections municipales les français ont
élu leur mère en faisant 40 % de
participation aux régionales ils ont élu
leur président de région sont 30% de
participation est la présidentielle 70%
de participation mais si je n'ai pas un
bon serveur non plus
législatif c'était 50 % si on ne prend
pas conscience que on met en danger la
légitimité de la position politique et
le fonctionnement même de la démocratie
si on change pas de mode de scrutin
c'est qu'on passe complètement à côté
des esprits la rentrée
il y aura de multiples combats il faut
quand il faut pas se limiter
il faut faire un il faut faire un bon
budget pour les français 2 il faut leur
donner une vision de l'avenir sur les
enjeux géopolitiques climatiques et
économiques qui sont devant nous de
nature à les rassurer il faut travailler
sur deux sujets spécifiques qui sont
ceux du mouvement démocrate depuis des
années 1 comment on partage mieux la
valeur dans ce pays et donc comment on
est capable d'augmenter les salaires
pour que le mérite des français qui
travaillent en mieux récompensés et 2
comment on représente mieux les
sensibilités dépenses à une de questions
pour conclure d'abord demain 5 septembre
sera commémorer le cinquantième
anniversaire du massacre des athlètes
israéliens aux jeux olympiques de munich
qui a marqué tous ceux qui étaient qui à
l'époque bas étaient étaient là à
l'époque dans la revue route pour ceux
qui suivent et qui ont les images en
tête voilà et à l'époque dans la rue vu
rouge edwy plenel le patron mediapart
avait déclaré être solidaire des
terroristes palestiniens donc de ces
jeux olympiques de munich ce qui avait
assassiné seat et israël qu'est ce que
ça vous inspire 50 ans après que
l'antisémitisme
est un combat de tous les jours c'était
antisémites et qu'au fond il ya une
il ya un lien année après année décennie
après décennie et on trouve toujours
un fond de propos
antisémite est aujourd'hui repris par
certaines tendances extrémistes dans
notre pays et donc ça doit être pour
nous à la fois une vigilance de tous les
jours et un combat où nous le savons
dernière question 50 ans justement après
ce massacre des jo de munich une
proposition de résolution signée par une
trentaine de duplessis de députés issus
des rangs denis pesce initiée par le
député communiste jean paul lecoq a été
déposée à l'assemblée en juillet
condamnant je le cite
l'institutionnalisation par israël d'un
régime d'apartheid aller à l'encontre du
peuple palestinien texa puisant l'état
hébreu d'avoir insisté instauré par d'un
système d'oppression discrimination
systématique dans l'intention de
maintenir la domination d'un groupe
racial juifs sur un autre l'assemblée a
ainsi d'abord qu'est ce qu'on pensait de
cette résolution très rapidement est-ce
que l'assemblée nationale peut être le
lieu où l'on ouvre de tels débats en
prenant sont écrits de tels propos
je fais d'abord une réflexion c'est que
un groupe racial ça n'existe pas
si dans la tête il faut pouvoir le
rappeler et écrire qu'un groupe racial
organiserait une politique c'est déjà
être raciste et déjà légitime et c'est
déjà justifié le racisme et puis c'est
donc c'est l'antisémitisme et puis au
fond bah je vous ai cité jean claude
gayssot tout à l'heure je le cite à
nouveau le racisme n'est pas une opinion
c'est un délit merci en tout cas patrick
manias d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation la première émission de cette
34e saison du forum radio j bonne fin
d'après-midi sur radio j et à dimanche
prochain et bonne nouvelle saison merci
à vous merci
[Musique]